haha the Joe Rogan experience one of the
biggest problems I'm looking at is who
determines what's essential and what's
not essential
yeah weed stores are central so we heard
it like in Michigan for instance they
were closing off certain parts of
certain stores did you hear about this
no so a lot of people took it because
there were photos of seeds at Walmart or
something where there was like tape
saying you can't you know this part of
stores closed and so the story went out
that you weren't allowed to buy seeds
anymore no story actually was that
stores over 50,000 feet had to close off
non-essential areas like flooring and
gardening and things like that and whose
to determine what is and isn't essential
about any of those services particularly
gardening if there's a time where you
want to have your own food readily
available in your backyard now's the
time well even think about just general
hardware if they're gonna shut that down
what if you what if a hole breaks up in
your floor you know your kid falls
through or something you got it fixed
yeah I mean that's that's a serious
safety issue so you've got these
governors determining what is essential
and what isn't I heard a good argument
for keeping liquor stores open because I
was like come on liquor stores but
someone said actually it is to prevent
people from going into detox from having
problems detoxing where they would take
up a hospital bed that we need
potentially need because of the virus i
that makes sense i also think about the
reality of you take away booze in a time
of a crisis yeah you're gonna see
people's nerves snap real quick have you
seen the video of this guy jogging down
the street he examines everybody's
recyclables yeah it's all filled with
vodka bottles and tequila and whiskey
and wine and so it goes from house to
house he's like let's see what they've
been up to oh well people are so
stressed out they're just getting
hammered yeah there's a lot of liver
damage when this is all a lot of horses
- yeah I heard that's that's going up oh
your people and domestic abuse and
thanks sure and suicide
[Applause]